autre sujet aujourd'hui netflix disney +
et les autres plateformes de diffusion
en ligne seront bientôt soumises à la
loi sur la radiodiffusion au canada le
ministre du patrimoine steven guilbeault
a déposé le projet de loi c-10 qui vise
à soumettre ces diffuseurs en ligne aux
mêmes obligations que les diffuseurs
traditionnels les plateformes en ligne
seront notamment forcé de produire une
certaine quantité de contenu francophone
et canadiens et leur contribution pour
atteindre 830 millions de dollars par
année d'ici trois ans avec nous ce soir
steven guilbeault ministre du patrimoine
canadien bonsoir monsieur guilbeault
bonsoir monsieur fillion vous faites
vous faites un pas aujourd'hui dans la
régulation de l'internet est ce que
l'internet sera de moins en moins libres
d'abord monsieur fillon je suis vraiment
désolé je suis au bureau du patrimoine
canadien il sent bien avec le système de
communication interne à s'entendre et on
vous entendiez monsieur guilbeault alesi
alors alors allons-y non pas du tout
bien au contraire
loin des limites et ce que nous allons
faire c'est permettre une augmentation
de des voies qui vont s'exprimer
grâce à ces investissements là que nous
allons demander aux géants du web de
faire dans l'écosystème culturel
québécois et canadien ok là on parle de
diffuseurs en ligne comme netflix comme
spotify par exemple qui devront
contribuer au contenu canadien
à quel niveau combien devront ils m
essentiellement ce que ce que ce que
nous cherchons à faire c'est de recréer
un équilibre dans la réglementation
canadienne autour de la question de la
radiodiffusion alors nous avons des
diffuseurs canadiens qui sont soumis à
cette réglementation la des obligations
d'investissement et nous avons ces
plateformes en ligne donc vous en avez
nommé plusieurs qui n'ont aucune
réglementation en donnant des pouvoirs
supplémentaires au crtc
ce que nous voulons faire ces règles
recréer un équilibre et que le que les
exigences envers ces plateformes le
soient semblables en terme de niveau des
phares vous serez pas nécessairement
même règlement parce qu'il ya des
entreprises canadiennes une des
entreprises internationales mais en
terme de niveau des phares donc
dépendamment des marchés dépendamment du
type d'entreprise dépendamment de la
taille généralement canada on est entre
25 % et 25 à 45 % des revenus qui
doivent être réinvestis un dé la culture
canadienne des revenus au canada c'est
soit exactement donc si netflix faisait
100 millions lui fait plus que ça là ce
serait au moins 25 millions à ce moment
là qui devrait être mis en contenu
canadien de 25 à 45 si on prend votre
exemple de 200 millions $ exact aurait
donc d'où vient le chiffre aujourd'hui
un chiffre qui circule et 830 millions
de dollars par année d'ici trois ans
comme on arrive à ce calcul là en
prenant cette formule-là donc dû 25 à 45
poussins et lorsqu'on regarde l'ensemble
des plateformes qui seraient assujettis
à cette nouvelle réglementation la leurs
dépenses au canada ça nous donne à peu
près ce que le crtc va faire son travail
votre mire des consultations donc ça
pourrait être un peu plus ça pourrait
être un peu moins
nos estimations nous amènent à penser
que ça va tourner autour de ça et c'est
de l'argent donc qui seraient réinvestis
dans du contenu dans de la production
canadienne parler parler les diffuseurs
en ligne a fait ce serait de l'argent
qui serait mis à la disposition après
soit les mécanismes exacts nous avons
différents fonds au canada le fonds
canadien pour les médias téléfilm donc
comment comment savoir opérationnaliser
c'est vraiment aux régulateurs de
déterminer sa c'est au législateur de se
mettre les deux mains dans ça le crtc
est composé d'experts du domaine la
radiodiffusion ils vont nous a aidé à
définir comment bien faire ça donc c'est
une première étape en quelque sorte pour
faire en sorte que les géants du web qui
font de la diffusion de contenus
contribuer davantage comme les chaînes
de télé comme les les diffuseurs
traditionnels
est ce que vous entendez aller plus loin
parce que il ya la taxation des géants
du web la france par exemple le fait ou
encore des redevances qui est qui avait
été promise à l'industrie des médias est
ce qu'on valait là aussi ce n'est qu'un
premier pas je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous un premier pas important parce
que je tiens quand même à préciser que
selon les projections du ministère
département ici
si rien n'est fait c'est un milliard de
dollars en moins qui serait disponible
pour les productions culturelles
canadiennes québécoises d'ici 2023
alors que alors que ce projet de loi va
permettre une injection supplémentaire
de presque 1 milliard de dollars donc
c'est excessivement important d'une part
d'autre part sur les médias nous y
travaillons j'ai été en contact au cours
des dernières semaines avec mes
homologues français australiens qui dans
un cas comme dans l'autre
arrivent avec leurs réglementations sur
sur la question et l'on parle pas tout à
fait des mêmes géant du web dans ce cas
ci on n'était pas vraiment de facebook
et google alors la france et l'australie
ne le font pas encore mais ils sont sur
le point de le faire
j'ai même parlé au président de l'organe
de réglementation en australie la
semaine dernière pour pourvoir dans le
détail kelly leur modèle est il ce qu'on
est en train de faire c'est de voir
comment nous on peut faire ça ici
contenu de nos institutions de nos lois
de nos règlements
mais je déposerai très bientôt un autre
projet de loi sur spécifiquement sur
cette question look et parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est important de le
comprendre les médias sociaux comme
facebook twitter ne sont pas google par
exemple ne sont pas touchés par la
réglementation n'est vraiment sûr la
diffusion de contenus le contenu audio
comme spotify ou le contenu vidéo comme
netflix exactly seul lit seul cas où on
peut penser à youtube par exemple ou
même facebook ou bourgault et seul cas
où la réglementation pourrait
s'appliquer c'est dans les cas où il
s'agirait comme des diffuseurs dont
google organise un grand spectacle par
exemple grand déploiement dans ce cas
précis la la la réglementation
s'appliquera mais sinon il se termine là
tu es ce que netflix et compagnie
accepte ça ce que vous proposez
aujourd'hui je pense que c'était à eux
qu'il faut poser la question nous avons
eu nous les avons rencontrés nous ne
nous la revoir présenté le projet de loi
mais mais l'intention que nous
poursuivons en élaborant ce projet de
loi là et on va on verra au cours des
prochains jours j'imagine qu'elle sera
là
centrafrique là ok c'était une guilbaud
merci beaucoup pour cet entretien
merci monsieur fillion bonne soirée